extended possession love again he's  going  a straight away trey to tie this game at  64.  manic gives it up bacon swing  love oh  caleb love connects  love is all around for the tar heels  he can't hunt the shot down faster he  couldn't get up to the offensive end roy  williams really loves it  davey just tosses it in the air and look  at love he can't wait to get a shot off  he's just in a zone finishing that one  off and same thing can be said right  here one dribble why not let her rip  good results  58.2 on the clock caleb love has scored  25  in the second half this season to make  the ncaa tournament growing pains as you  but davis said it wasn't one leader it  was everybody coming together